well in in America this is not a new  evil in the world but in America the  suppression of free speech the amount of  censorship is is brand new America  El Woodrow Wilson flirted with it  but outside of the Woodrow Wilson era we  have never had a suppression of free  speech that was the one thing every  every American agreed with 45 percent of  Young Americans according to Pew which I  tend to trust  say the following  I believe in free speech except for hate  speech and they don't realize because  they they've not been taught to think  logically they don't realize that that's  an oxymoron it's a self-contradictory  statement if you don't believe in free  speech for hate speech you don't believe  in free speech what do you believe in  free speech for only speech you agree  with everything else is hate speech this  is what the leftist taught them